but yeah so many beautiful women in La
it's crazy ladies you guys know how to
look good you know all these tricks
that's how women figured out to take the
selfie up here that was all you ladies
you know where your good sight lines are
I think that's why women like tall guys
just some guy looking at you from your
best angle 100% of the time all day
long right that's why you don't mess
with short guys just some guy like gez
look at the triple chin on this broad
holy
hell I'm glad I'm not single it's hard
to talk to ladies that's scary ladies
hit on menm more hit on us you can say
what whatever you want to a guy I had an
older lady approached me once she goes
oo I'm going to kidnap you I was
like I was like wow I could never say
that to a
woman I say that to a lady she calls the
police you know
yeah yeah I would be curious to know
what a woman could say that would offend
me like all right I'm GNA I'm going to
take you home I'm gonna drug
you take advantage of you and film it i'
be like at least let me pay for the
Uber